- Good morning ladies and gentlemen.
On behalf of the President
of Yale University,
the Commanding Officer
of Yale Naval Reserve
Officers Training Corps
and commander of Yale Air Force
Reserve Officer Training Corps,
welcome to the Annual President's Review.
We specifically acknowledge
and thank representatives
in attendance from Fairfield University,
Quinnipiac University,
Sacred Heart University,
Southern Connecticut State University,
Western Connecticut State University,
and the University of New Haven.
To you and to all distinguished guests
families, and friends, welcome.
Today's music is provided
by the United States Navy Band Northeast.
Today's review is conducted
by the midshipmen and cadets
of Yale Naval and Air Force
Reserve Officer Training Corps.
Present day reviews have their basis
in both history and tradition.
The mass formation of
troops on one long line
at close interval, made possible
the massing of firepower
from muzzle loaded muskets of yesterday.
In those early days, the
line of battle was just that,
a line of two or three ranks,
and looked much like the parade formation
you will see today, the adjuvant
forms the line for battle.
- Stand, attention!
(bright music)
(indistinct) attention!
Soldiers, attention.
(indistinct)
(trumpet playing)
(upbeat band music)
Company, halt!
(indistinct)
Ready front (indistinct).
(officers talking)
(indistinct)
- Yale University Naval
Reserve Officer Training Corps
all present.
(indistinct)
- (indistinct) all present.
- Yale University (indistinct)
officer training corps
all present.
(indistinct)
- Order (indistinct).
(indistinct) march.
(indistinct) halt.
(indistinct)
- Ladies and gentlemen,
please rise for the arrival
of the official party.
Air Force Reserve Officer Training Corps
Unit detachment 009 arriving.
Naval Reserve Officer Training Corps
Unit Yale University arriving.
(bell clanging)
Yale University arriving.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please remain standing
for the posting of the
colors, the national anthem
and the invocation.
(indistinct)
(upbeat band music)
("The Star Spangled Banner" playing)
- Order!
(indistinct)
- Chaplain Sharon Kugler,
Yale University Chaplain
will now give the invocation.
- Good morning.
Please join me in the spirit of prayer.
Almighty God, source of all truth.
Here we stand humbled by
the breadth of service
both past and present in our midst.
We stand proud of what
has been made possible
because we have committed
ourselves to making your world
a better place through
our willing spirits,
able bodies and courageous hearts.
Although today is a
celebration and rightly so,
we remember those who have
given their lives in service
to their country and we hold close those
who are currently deployed
and ask that your gentle hand
protect them and guide them safely home.
Now, may our hearts move
from gratitude to inspiration
as your divine spirit empowers us
with a renewed vision and purpose.
Let us begin this review
lifted by splendor,
ignited by camaraderie.
Together in our many
voices, strengths and faiths
as your loving people, we say, amen.
- Please be seated.
The President's Review
has several purposes.
First, it serves to honor
and thank the leadership
of the universities that
host and support our units.
This event also serves as an opportunity
to publicly recognize the
achievements of the midshipmen
and cadets you see here
today who have distinguished
themselves during the academic year.
Ladies and gentlemen, Commanding
Officer Yale University
Naval Reserve Officer Training
Corps, Captain Ron Withrow.
- Good morning everyone.
President Salovey, General
Raymond, fellow ROTC commanders,
ROTC representatives
from our partner colleges
and universities, Provost
Strobel, Dean Lewis,
Yale administrators, faculty and staff,
alumni and supporters who I
will collectively refer to
as friends of ROTC, award
presenters representing a host
of organizations, friends and families,
welcome all to the Yale
ROTC President's Review.
This is a great opportunity
to showcase our Yale ROTC
midshipmen and cadets,
recognize our top performers
and also recognize our
graduating class of 2023
who'll be commissioning
in just a few short weeks.
This event wouldn't be
possible without the hard work
from several outstanding individuals.
I want to especially thank
Marine Option Midshipman
Third Class Evan Quang, the
Midshipman Officer in Charge
responsible for planning this grand event,
US Marine Corps Gunnery Sergeant Chaz King
for providing drill
instructor grade instruction.
Our senior administrative
coordinator, Liz Vildaki
for coordinating with numerous
supporting organizations,
and our MC, US Marine
Corps Captain Ratzy May,
and many, many others.
Before I introduce our reviewing
officer President Salovey
for his remarks, I want to talk
to you a bit about history,
duty and leadership.
For those of you seeing this
for the first time today
the pass in review consists
of an award ceremony
and a military pass in review.
So first, a bit of history
regarding the passenger review
to expound on what the MC
Captain May has already stated.
The pass in review is
a formal time-honored
ceremony dates back to
before the Civil War.
The purpose of the ceremony
was to formally present
the military command to a new commander
or commanding officer.
Probably visible to most of you would be
the pass in review
before the newly sworn in
president of the United
States, our Commander in Chief,
which follows the inaugural ceremony.
Another example would be
the pass in review conducted
at the recruit graduation
ceremonies marking the completion
of bootcamp and enlistment
into active duty.
One in which this guy
participated in 1985 by the way,
and yet I retain my youthful appearance
or at least I keep telling myself that
when I look in the mirror every morning.
The military pass in review
has transformed over time
to also include honoring
the hard work and dedication
of military members in the
performance of their duties
as we will do today.
So what are the duties
of cadets and midshipmen?
They're not only college students
but distinguish themselves
by committing to serve their
country as future soldiers,
sailors, marines, airmen and guardians.
They carry the same course
load that other students
on campus carry, participating
in and leading the same
diverse palette of extracurricular
activities, sports,
student, government
affinity groups, etc., etc.
But they're different in
that they have taken an oath
to serve their country in
preparation to defend the freedoms
and the liberties that
all US citizens enjoy.
Committing to undergoing
intensive instruction
to prepare them and in fact
transform them mentally, morally
and physically into warriors
in the profession of arms.
And now looking
specifically at our seniors
who will be commissioning
in just a few short weeks.
I know each of you have been
giving considerable thought
to the oath of office that you will take.
As current Navy Service Chief
Admiral Mike Gilday stated,
the oath is what binds us together.
It is the foundation of our profession.
It is our north star, it defines us.
Wise words that apply
equally to all because cadets
and midshipmen, no matter
the color of the uniform,
the oath is the same
and it will define you.
And ladies and gentlemen,
looking at the world we live in
today, we need these creative
and energetic young men
and women more than ever
to lead our armed forces
in the coming critical years.
Last year, Vice Admiral Roy Kitchener,
he's the head of our surface Navy,
hosted a junior officer training
symposium that was titled
Embracing Ingenuity to
Sharpen Our Competitive Edge.
But this wasn't simply training
for these young leaders.
They weren't in receive only mode.
Admiral Kitchener used the
symposium to foster wide ranging
discussion centered on
building efficiencies
within the force, improving
business practices,
and as a venue for junior
officers to present
current challenges in the
surface force that they saw
along with proposed solutions.
Why?
Because as the Admiral
stated, junior officers play
an integral role in solving
problems on the waterfront.
Commandant of the US Marine
Corps General David Berger
shared similar sentiments when
he stated small unit leaders
who are well trained, who
have experience and maturity
to make decisions and are
empowered to make decisions
in lieu of detailed guidance are powerful
even when outnumbered and even
when up against formations
that are two, three, four times as big.
This is the bread and
butter of the Marine Corps.
I acknowledge these are
naval centric examples
that I've given, but the
Navy and Marine Corps
certainly doesn't hold a
monopoly on challenging problems
and the need to solve them.
I'm sure all service branches
agree that we must look
to these enterprising,
energetic and creative young men
and women for solutions.
Whether we are talking
about the Navy's get real,
get better mindset, the
Army's people first,
winning matters
transformational philosophy
or the Air Force's
accelerate, change or lose
strategic approach, at the end of the day,
without intelligent, creative
committed and empowered
leaders manning our
enlisted and officer ranks,
they're just cliched empty catchphrases.
It takes real concern, real
leadership and a willingness
to get into the fight, make
mistakes and try, try again.
So to the cadets and
midshipmen standing here
on behalf of all the commanders present,
I charge each of you to
be the transformational
junior leaders and decision
makers that our nation needs.
Because good leadership does
not just propel the military
forward, it also propels our
nation and our world forward
and we at ROTC enjoy a
great partnership with Yale
in this regard.
Working together to develop intelligent,
caring and collaborative
leaders to transform
a world for the better.
Critical to this partnership
has been the leadership
and the guiding vision of
President Peter Salovey.
Yale's mission statement reads
in part that Yale educates
aspiring leaders worldwide who
serve all sectors of society.
One can easily see the
similarity in missions
and how this contributes to a supportive,
effective partnership.
This is no doubt a direct
reflection of President Salovey's
inspirational leadership and vision.
So at this time I would like to introduce
our reviewing official and host,
the 23rd president of Yale
University and the Chris Argyris
Professor of Psychology,
Peter Salovey. (claps)
(audience claps)
- Thank you so much.
Appreciate that.
Thank you Captain Withrow.
I appreciate the kind
introduction and I'd also like
to thank Colonel Granholm
for his inspired leadership
of Yale's Air Force Reserve
Officers Training Corps unit.
Both Captain Withrow and Colonel Granholm
will be retiring after this semester.
And so before I proceed any
further, I want to offer
my heartfelt appreciation
and that of a grateful
Yale community for both
of your commitments
to advancing stability in the world.
As we wish you both the
very best for the wonderful
new chapter on which
you are about to embark,
we know that you will
remain very much a part
of the Yale family.
With the approach of their retirements,
please join me in recognizing
Captain Ron Withrow
and Colonel George Granholm's
exceptional service
to this country. (claps)
(audience claps)
Thank you.
They have been wonderful
leaders here on our campus.
To all the parents,
loved ones, active duty
military members, veterans
here, I extend a warm greeting
on behalf of my colleagues
across the university.
And I wish to welcome cadets,
liaisons and leaders here
today from our Air Force
affiliated universities,
Fairfield University,
Quinnipiac University,
Sacred Heart University,
Southern Connecticut State University,
University of New Haven,
Wesleyan University
and Western Connecticut State University.
The sense of service we mark
on this historic occasion
dates to the founding of our institution
and of the republic.
Here are just a few examples.
In 1701, Yale became the
first American University
to inscribe service to society explicitly
in its founding legislation.
Scores of Yaleys have
served with distinction
in every major conflict
since the Revolutionary War.
Yale Air Force ROTC
was one of the original
77 senior air ROTC units
established by an order
General Eisenhower signed.
And Yale was also among the
initial group of universities
to establish an ROTC program
more than a century ago.
Army ROTC in 1917, followed
by Naval ROTC in 1926
and the Air Force ROTC in 1946.
At the time, Major General
Robert M. Danford predicted
the program would become one
of the many priceless heritages
of future generations at Yale.
When I look out at all of you,
I can see that he was right.
The 55 Air Force cadets
and the 31 midshipmen
currently participating
in Yale's ROTC program
are carrying forward the proud
legacy of those before them.
This includes the valor of
nearly 30,000 Yaleys who served
in the First and Second world
wars, Korea and Vietnam.
And the spirit of sacrifice
that links these military men
and women is a hallmark of
the spirit of Yale itself.
It is a desire to serve, to
look beyond self-interest.
It is the desire to
contribute to the common good
and it is in short the desire
to improve the world today
and for future generations.
Indeed, that is how our
mission statement begins
and this is the call the
class of 2023 has answered.
Your decision to serve our country
and the armed forces is
vital at this moment.
We can see the increasing pressure
of the spirit of division
around the globe.
Yet today we salute your accomplishments
and we can also see a
thriving spirit of service.
It's a spirit forged over centuries.
Indeed, the fabric of our
nation is woven by individuals
who have defended it for nearly 250 years.
Their resilience and wisdom
helped build a nation
and their strength helped bind it together
during difficult times.
Their courage helped save a
world torn apart by war twice.
Their determination has protected millions
from a life of oppression and hardship.
Their compassion has brought
food, clothing, shelter
and medicine to those who needed it most.
And their unselfish motives
in the face of adversity
brought hope to those who are suffering.
Throughout your time, I've
observed the same sense
of optimism, courage,
and selflessness in you.
And I know the class of 2023 will manage
to make us even more
proud in the years ahead.
Now I'd like to congratulate
all our soon-to-be graduates
and express my appreciation
to all our midshipmen
and cadets for their dedication to service
and their many contributions to Yale
and their universities and colleges.
You'll soon be second
lieutenants and ensigns
serving as America's
ambassadors around the world.
You'll face challenges and opportunities
in a rapidly changing global climate
with incredible technological
advances that both connect
people across nations and cultural borders
but also pose unpredictable
security risks.
You'll also experience shifts in political
and environmental landscapes.
Yet regardless of what
trials you may face,
I am confident that you, like
the generations of Yaleys
who contributed to this
country before you,
will lead and serve the greater good.
We're so proud of what
you have accomplished here
and we eagerly look forward
to all you will achieve
in the future as you
build on Yale's tradition
of loyal service to
community and to country.
Thank you very much for joining us today
and to all of you thank you,
and please accept my most
heartfelt congratulations.
Thank you very much.
(audience claps)
- We will now begin with
the presentation of awards.
The Veterans of Foreign
Wars Award is presented
by Mr Mario Richards,
Veterans of Foreign Wars
Connecticut State Commander.
This award recognizes one
midshipman and one cadet
who demonstrate a positive
attitude towards ROTC,
outstanding professional
attributes and officer potential.
This year's Naval ROTC recipient
is Midshipman Andrew Chirkleton
and Air Force ROTC recipient
is Cadet McKenna Picton.
(audience claps)
The General Society of
the War of 1812 Award
is presented by Mr Lee Tryon,
secretary of the General
Society of the War of 1812
in the state of Connecticut.
This award recognizes one
midshipman and one cadet
who represent the cherishing,
maintenance and extension
of the institutions of American freedom
and foster true patriotism
and love of country.
This year's naval ROTC
recipient is Midshipman
Samuel Moyenke and Air
Force ROTC recipient
is Cadet Caitlin Atlasman.
(audience claps)
The Yale Veteran's Association
True to Her Traditions Award
is presented by Mr Joshua
Ray, Yale College class
of 2013 in Holly Hermas, Yale University
incoming liaison for
veteran and military affairs
and Colonel United
States Air Force Reserve.
The mission of Yale University
is to educate leaders.
Additionally, Yale has a
long and glorious tradition
of service and defense of our nation.
The Yale Veterans
Association is very pleased
to present its True to Her
Tradition's Leadership Award
to honor and commemorate
these ideals to the midshipman
and cadet who have demonstrated
a strong commitment
to them over the past year.
This year's Naval ROTC
recipient is Midshipman
Victoria Smithson and
Air Force ROTC recipient
is Cadet Nida (indistinct).
(audience claps)
The Yale Veterans Network
Annual ROTC award is presented
by Miss Tamika Hollis co-chair
of the Yale Veterans Network.
In the spirit of the Yale
Veterans Network's charge
to connect veterans on
campus, this award recognizes
one midshipman and one
cadet who have demonstrated
commitment to the Yale
ROTC program through
outstanding leadership
discipline, character,
citizenship, and academic achievement.
This year's naval ROTC
recipient is Midshipman
Juliana Calvert and Air
Force ROTC recipient
is Cadet Grace Zerba.
(audience claps)
The order of the Purple Heart
National Leadership Award
is presented by Major Daniel Edinger,
United States Army retired
and Order of the Purple Heart
Regional Commander, and Mr Mike Perone,
Order of the Purple Heart State Commander.
This award recognizes the
demonstrated leadership ability
of one midshipman and one cadet
enrolled in a university ROTC program.
This year's Naval ROTC
recipient is Midshipman
Tory Emha and Air Force ROTC recipient
is Cadet Thomas Nardini.
(audience claps)
The Rear Admiral Frederick B. Warder Award
for outstanding achievement is presented
by Captain Tom Olson,
United States Navy retired
and Vice President of the
Naval Submarine League
Nautilus Chapter.
The Rear Admiral Frederick B. Warder Award
for outstanding achievement
established in 1986
recognizes a graduating naval ROTC senior
approved for entry into the Navy's nuclear
propulsion program as submarine officers.
The awardee has demonstrated
superior sustained performance
in a difficult and challenging academic
and operational environment,
and as a result has earned
the commanding officer's
nomination for this distinctive award.
This year's recipient
is Midshipman Dan Wynn.
(audience claps)
The Corporal Langdon Laws
Ricketts Award is presented
by Lieutenant Colonel Andrew Gorgounes
United States Marine
Corps and Marine Fellow
at the Jackson School of Global Affairs.
Corporal Ricketts graduated
from Yale College in 1916
and was killed in action
during World War I
at Mont Blanc in 1918.
A decorated Marine who was the recipient
of the Croix de Guerre, all
accounts maintained that
Corporal Ricketts had a knack
for maintaining his wits
in the face of chaos.
Importantly, he was an enlisted man,
a non-commissioned officer.
NCOs are the backbone of the Marine Corps.
More than any other service
the Marines place special trust
and confidence in the
abilities of their junior
most enlisted leadership.
It is this sort of
Marine that the recipient
of the Corporal Langdon
Laws Ricketts Award
will be called upon to lead
shortly after their graduation
from Yale College.
This year's recipient is
Midshipman Katherine Yang.
(audience claps)
The Hiram Bingham III award is presented
by Jack Beecher, outgoing
military and veteran liaison.
This award in honor of the
esteemed Yale Academic explorer
and politician, Hiram
Bingham III, is presented
to urge its awardee to
always fight for truth,
justice and mercy and to
serve as a reminder to all
to fear nothing except to do wrong.
This award recognizes a senior
Yale Air Force ROTC cadet
who exhibits the highest
level of integrity
and American citizenship.
This year's recipient is
Cadet James Crossdale.
(audience claps)
The Robert N. Thorpe Award is presented
by Colonel Granholm.
Robert N. Thorpe was an
esteemed teacher and mentor
to generations of Air
Force language specialists.
This award recognizes a
Yale Air Force ROTC cadet
for excellence in academic achievement
and for inspiring others toward
global cultural awareness.
This year's recipient is
Cadet Isabella Schembri.
(audience claps)
The Yale Veterans Association
Class of 1966 Sword
is presented by Mr Tom Oakladen,
Yale College class of 1966
and President Emeritus of the
Yale Veterans Association.
This sword is awarded
to a naval ROTC student
who possesses a demonstrated
leadership ability
and who has earned the
respect of Yale classmates
inside and outside of
the Naval ROTC program.
Through their efforts, they
have materially contributed
to bridging the civilian military divide,
and by exerting leadership in both spheres
have enhanced the prestige
of the Naval ROTC program
on campus and reinforced the
Yale tradition of engaging
in service to society as a
desirable life objective.
This year's recipient is
Midshipman Kevin Walsh.
(audience claps)
The Admiral David S. Ingalls
Leadership Award is presented
by Mr Redmond S. Ingalls,
Yale College class of 1998
and grandson of Admiral David S. Ingalls.
David S. Ingalls Yale
College class of 1920
was a Navy's first Ace
with five confirmed kills
in World War I.
He later served as assistant
secretary of the Navy
for aeronautics where he tripled
the number of Navy aircraft
while advocating for a fully
deployable carrier task force.
At Yale he twice captained
the men's hockey team.
The Admiral David S. Ingalls
Award recognizes a senior
Yale Naval ROTC midshipman
who shows uncommon ability
and leadership potential.
This year's recipient is
Midshipman Benjamin Marker.
(audience claps)
The Yale Veterans ROTC
Fund Award is presented
by Mr Peter Salovey,
president of Yale University.
This award recognizes a
senior in the Army, Naval
and Air Force ROTC units
who is in good standing
in their unit with excellent academic
and military performance records.
This year's Army recipient
is Cadet Alexandra Racough,
Marine Corps recipient
is Midshipman Aaron Khoo,
Navy recipient is
Midshipman Joseph Murphy,
Air Force recipient is Cadet Brian Regan.
(audience claps)
This year marks the first
presentation of the Yale Veterans
ROTC Fund award to a
cadet selected for service
in the United States Space Force.
To commemorate this event,
accompanying President Salovey
who will present this award
is General John W. Raymond,
the former chief of Space Operations
of the United States Space Force.
The Space Force recipient
is Cadet Charlotte Vick.
(audience claps)
This concludes the individual
award presentations.
To our midshipmen and
cadets who are undertaking
extra academic coursework,
undergoing physical training,
participating in numerous
community events and willingly
have pledged to serve their
country upon graduation,
please join me in giving
them a round of applause.
(audience claps)
- Battalion, attention.
Officer.
- Officer.
Yale University Reserve
Officer Training Corps
(indistinct) April 20, 2023.
(indistinct)
Captain (indistinct) United
States Navy (indistinct).
Officers (indistinct).
March.
(upbeat band music)
(indistinct)
Ladies and gentlemen,
we will now recognize the class of 2023.
Please hold your applause until everyone
has been recognized.
Cadet April Kim from
Fredericksburg, Virginia
of Pauli Murray College.
Service assignment,
transportation core officer.
First assignment, basic
officer leader course
Fort Lee, Virginia.
Cadet Alexandra Racough
from New Haven, Connecticut
of Branford College.
Service assignment, medical
service core officer.
First assignment, basic
officer leader course,
Fort Sam, Houston, Texas.
Midshipman Dan Wynn from
Falls Church, Virginia
of Trumbull College.
Service assignment,
submarine warfare officer.
First assignment, Naval
Nuclear Power School
joint base Charleston, South Carolina.
Midshipman Aaron Khoo from
Diamond Bar California
of Benjamin Franklin College.
Service assignment, Marine Corps officer.
First assignment, the basic
school of Marine Corps
base Quantico, Virginia.
Midshipman Benjamin Marker
from Portsmouth, Rhode Island
of Jonathan Edwards College.
Service assignment, naval aviator.
First assignment, Naval Flight School,
Naval Air Station Pensacola, Florida.
Midshipman, Joseph Murphy
from Milwaukee, Wisconsin
of Ezra Styles College.
Service assignment, naval
intelligence officer.
First assignment, basic
intelligence officer training,
Naval Air Station Dam
Neck Annex, Virginia.
Midshipman Emily
Quisenberry from Glen Eagle,
Maryland of Grace Hopper College.
Service assignment,
Naval Reactors engineer.
First assignment, Naval
Reactors preliminary training,
Naval Reactors headquarters,
district of Columbia.
Midshipman Kevin Walsh
from San Diego, California
of Pearson College.
Service assignment, naval aviator.
First assignment, Naval Flight School,
Naval Air Station, Pensacola, Florida.
Midshipman Katherine Yang
from Coast Cobb, Connecticut
of Branford College.
Service assignment, Marine
Corps Officer Candidate.
First assignment, Marine Corps
Officer Candidate School,
Marine Corps base Quantico, Virginia.
Midshipman Thomas Zamora
from San Diego, California
of Morse College.
Service assignment, Marine
Corps Officer Candidate.
First assignment, Marine Corps
Officer Candidate School,
Marine Corps base Quantico, Virginia.
Cadet James Crossdale from
Burlington, Massachusetts
of the University of New Haven.
Service assignment, Air Force pilot.
First assignment,
undergraduate pilot training,
Laughlin Air Force Base, Texas.
Cadet Danielle Daley
from Alexandria, Virginia
of Benjamin Franklin College.
Service assignment, remotely
piloted aircraft pilot.
First assignment, remotely
piloted aircraft course,
Randolph Air Force Base, Texas.
Cadet Presley Hill from
Franklin, Connecticut
of the University of New Haven.
Service assignment, Air
Force intelligence officer.
First assignment, intelligence officer,
Technical School of Goodfellow
Air Force Base, Texas.
Cadet Quentin Holand from
the District of Columbia
of Berkeley College.
Service assignment,
cyberspace operations officer.
First assignment,
undergraduate cyber training,
Keesler Air Force Base, Mississippi.
Cadet William Klein from
St. Petersburg, Florida
of Branford College.
Service assignment,
space operations officer.
First assignment, Master's
program in Aeronautics
and Astronautics, Massachusetts
Institute of Technology,
Cambridge, Massachusetts.
Cadet Brian Regan from
Redondo Beach, California
of Morris College.
Service assignment, Air
Force helicopter pilot.
First assignment, Master's
program in aerospace engineering,
Georgia Institute of
Technology, Atlanta, Georgia.
Cadet Cole Snedeger from
Atlantic Highlands, New Jersey,
of Pearson College.
Service assignment, Air
Force intelligence officer.
First assignment, intelligence
officer technical school,
Goodfellow Air Force Base, Texas.
Cadet Charlotte Vick
from Englewood, Florida
of the University of New Haven.
Service assignment, Space
Force intelligence officer.
First assignment, 345th
Recruiting Squadron,
Scott Air Force Base, Illinois.
Cadet Matthew Vidirelli
from Bethel, Connecticut
of Pauli Murray College.
Service assignment,
cyberspace operations officer.
First assignment,
undergraduate cyber training,
Keesler Air Force Base, Mississippi.
Cadet Kate Yeager from Salinas, California
of Silliman College.
Service assignment,
information operations officer.
First assignment, 352nd
Special Operations Wing,
Royal Air Force,
Mildenhall, United Kingdom.
Cadet Grace Zerba from Dayton,
Ohio of Saybrook College.
Service Assignment, Acquisitions Officer.
First assignment, Eglin
Air Force Base, Florida.
Ladies and gentlemen, please
join me in a round of applause
for our graduating seniors.
(audience claps)
Ladies and gentlemen, please
rise for the benediction
and remain standing
for the pass in review,
service songs and departure
of the official party.
- My sisters and brothers, let
us go forth from this place
in peace with wisdom and understanding,
with compassion and mercy,
with courage and commitment.
May we be blessed this day and every day
by the shimmering light
of our God who creates,
sustains and embraces all life.
Amen.
- Battalion, attention!
March, turn around in review.
- Aye, sir.
Pass in review.
(indistinct)
March.
(upbeat band music)
March left, march.
Company, halt.
- Company, halt.
(upbeat band music continues)
(upbeat band music)
- (indistinct) the command.
- Aye, sir.
Company commanders
(indistinct) your companies.
(indistinct).
Dismissed.
- Ladies and gentlemen, this
concludes today's ceremony.
We invite all presenters and
award recipients to join us
at the center of court to take photos.
Thank you for attending
and please join us for
luncheon in the lobby upstairs.
(audience claps)
(mellow music)